the same deviations
[Music]
we should enter shift your weight one
foot other foot skip your weight
don't double pivot don't double in turn
Center the forehead shift your weight
this way
the Ox keys to the back to the back then
don't leave in here start the
firefighter me
so this maneuver is here is just one big
eternity
rotate this bikes gonna keep rotating
you see see how it keeps turning don't
leave it there boom boom keep it
rotating boom
turn it so same open the box
don't pull it like this up like that you
want the fight to keep turning you want
to hit me keep turning so you stay in
the back 101 to see my hands stay with
my Center
Watsky then the 10 car
the knee must be over the midline of the
foot
my furthest young aspect is my kneecap
to my toes my furthest hidden aspect is
going to be my weight at mid foot so
I'll never be on the front foot and heel
weight will never be like that so the
furthest I go forward or my weight is on
the front foot is knee to toes the
furthest back I can go is weight to mid
foot what we call mid foot garnet yes
okay if my way too easy to go past mid
foot then I shift it to the back foot
you see that it won't stay on the front
foot you guys get that okay so now when
I go back and I shift right how much
weight do you think by I can put on the
back leg what would be the furthest back
my weight can be on the back foot mid
foot just like the front you see that so
I can't shift it we're on back here
if I had to shift it back there what do
I need to do step you see and what's the
nearest step knee to toes you see you
get that okay so that doesn't change so
when I move forward I will take my
from me to my jawline then that's as far
as that goes and now this back foot is
going to move to go forward you got that
okay
so I never shift to mid foot weight and
take a step I have to complete the young
face needed toes then this foot cannot
move and I'll show you some resistance
and if I step prior to the dog things
being completed he will move my center
of gravity backwards so here I am at mid
foot on the front foot not at full young
and the second I tried to walk people
push me you see that but if I shift you
complete the full young face then
there's a positive angle on the front
foot and I can walk forward do you guys
understand okay now what I do in
attorney I can't change that it's still
the in your own world so when it comes
time to turn me I can't make my knee go
inside that that line down the middle of
my foot length wise if I if I want my
knee over here my foot has to go over
there you see that and how far that I
moved off into the turn so what what
no that's right mighty goes over the
toes try to get it right
the front is forward knee over the toes
the furnace back mid-foot wait do you
got it
where's the John face ed toes where's
the gin face head mid-foot wait now I'm
going to turn no what's wrong it's not
in alignment with the medium of the foot
do you guys see that so I would have to
fix it here you see then how much
rotation can I get where does the
rotation stop the end of the young face
you get it when the need is it over the
toys you can't keep going you can't go
like that you're gonna have a bad
posture you can't ground
you're not going wider you checking
yourself out got it
okay so let's look at double pivoting
I'm equally weighted got it and when I
start to rotate both feet what's
actually happening to my body what do
you think if I bend these rules of
complete the young phase utilize the in
face no I'm trying to stay at Woodford
weight and do this maneuver which is why
you always lose your balance and you
mind it like this you get
this is called falling down into any
other sport okay so we never double dip
it you complete the even young faces as
one foot until you can't then you
complete the yin and Yan phases on the
other foot
okay so I'm doing the first maneuver I
step over here you go like this this is
not weak being into your position and
this is me cleaning my teeth now look at
me laterally you think then I'm going to
show you the inherent weakness your
inner and he's just going to push my
mouth on this plane and I don't have
anything down so he's trying to pull my
hand on that plane and I won't have any
support there well when I am here like
this and I go to turn in the resistance
of his mask is a pulling energy you get
it so I'm pulling against this weak base
what usually happens he's stronger
happier
like that you get it so we don't do that
we go to the ground with foot one yeah
young turn who bring the other foot in
okay now I have a brown defector what
I'm feeling
so he's pushing on me and he's just
sending energy into that foot the back
foot do you see he's he's pushing
pushing pushing pushing and he's just
grounding me all right my hair like this
good enough you guys get it so first
move one two
grab the back foot you're in full y'all
at the back foot whoa Oh pull y'all on
the back foot we're in the back corner
in the back corner back here back here
turn around
food I'm here
over there push I'm here over here push
under the other foot is irrelevant he's
all being sector on the on foot
okay let's get there me so remember
single
that single banks we did it on whatever
right here's where you did it okay
and you did it when you injure your way
[Music]
right how's it changes on burn up same
beginning same single to it I'm going to
step I'm gonna shift my weight that's
where this hand comes to my head right
here then single pivot again you got
single pivot bull weight single
pivot single pivot
same beginning is what goes behind him
onto one foot shift
[Music]
say beginning full behind him single
pivot step
let's look at something it's a back
break fault
yes that we should be going for the back
rainfall is not the result of him to be
accelerated backwards you got it okay
secondly and you need not pull or push
he can do right back to me okay so if I
push off his arm we can push on this on
if I pull on his arm he can pull on this
one that's not like Tito those are all
clashes okay so wait when you do that
you do we'll just sleep with a voltage
for now under double dead and you see if
I move this time from my ride to my back
he is equally capable of moving it to
his right you see that and then the same
thing if I go over here and I pull his
arm from back to front he is equally
capable of one another none of this is
like you is you're all gone gone gone
class so you have to not do the obvious
okay so I'm gonna throw him backwards by
keeping Android phone and I'm not gonna
make his armor to go from front to back
I'm gonna keep it in the front of my
body and keep it working off of a circle
not a linear line pulling front to back
okay
so when I do
and I put it here on my head
I don't disconnect so I can do that his
arm is gonna go around in this circle
and he keeps going forward but you end
up and she won money do you see that so
here we go he's there
[Music]
so it's a bigger circle so 1 1 ta keep
going forward you got that
so you can't you never outside of safety
reasons you guess you'd never have to
walk backwards into my technique
see you don't have hair like this right
and when I come back you're like who can
vouch for you
oh that's right ok that should kick your
ass ok
[Music]
we will eventually look like when you
want it to look like okay let's go
every day is time you okay you can't
just do the pieces whenever you want
okay so the first one Tommy to keep them
going now I believe my house here in
space and I step I'm disconnecting and
he's just standing still
that Brigade standing still is
[Music]
I have to do that by moving with the
proper time okay well right now we are
again playing by the foot maneuver we
should so he's not there so when I take
this this shoulder goes out here if I
just step without the single pivot
liquid my spine is relation to this body
not living here that's not the same but
when I shoot my weight on the other foot
but if I'm inside the spiral do you see
that okay now when I take the tent on if
I go here and then bring my spine over
know from this foot turn again where do
you need you to stay inside of that stay
inside that you should never see you so
here we all move we're gonna move now
I'm on one point and I can just keep
moving around that one point you see and
I'm about to running out of my space I
take that other ship to keep me back
there right and now I'm going to be
inside of him as I do the turn but not
here he
so just like the motet you should be
facing him on the turn so same thing on
you it up which you can do if you don't
dip it right there
open okay try to the two problems we're
trying to work the first one
you see that we got that that does not
work you're pulling you're pulling it on
against him pulling on you that is not
Aikido so you'll end up in sheet one
time you don't believe me so we're gonna
take the footwork out
all you're gonna do is keep turning
turning turning and he will you'll see
that it does get there okay so I'm just
here I'm in this pocket and I just keep
dirty I don't need to go like this and
when I go like that you can just pull it
[Music]
and that was balanced the whole time
watch the other one no bonus I actually
give him back his balance then I think
no keep his movie Circle Circle Circle
tiny tiny no but I do it I try to turn
the place
try see see if my balance I have all of
it and I should be here all right you
push and you leave this here like that
should already and look here I am go
right right I keeping her in that angle
let's say she pulls she's strong enough
to pull out doesn't matter
I'm in the back okay so I keep going
forward forward the drill here don't
come back and give her a baklava keep er
going in the drill and I make smaller
circles smaller proffers
okay so we're gonna do the drill but
we're going to take it to down when I
take it down okay
yes because it's avenged
I bought the shoulder still pulling up
do you see
putt and it's in the turn so I'm here
not tight enough I'm going to keep
turning okay
don't send them up the other way okay so
now we take time and you can do it as
long as you single pivot
okay so when I had my feet like this
the single pivot was between my feet
that was an axis of rotation but when I
have my feet apart
middle here okay so say beginning long
Japan movie singleton and keeps further
he's 31
[Music]
keep it turning sometimes you want to
keep it turning
okay so that's our next one
that's why is it being treated okay so
all in here but now we stop the
technique and then you do we do okay but
remember he was already following you
see so I am now anything is descent I
don't pull his arm I move in he D me on
his body makes his legs come around that
makes his arm come where I wanted to go
I didn't pull his arm in the beginner
you're gonna have to pull but in this
one you don't pull because people
falling and you never pulled the arm
okay so go right corner try to the
actual victory if you still having
problems trying to begin injury but no
it's a beginner entry the technique has
stopped and you're working on the
separate thing okay